huge week for democrats and joe biden as
they kick off their national convention
tonight
and president trump set to give a speech
going after biden in the key
battleground state of wisconsin
let's bring that to you as for the
democrats gone are the crowds confetti
and balloons
with most events taking place in the
virtual world michelle obama delivering
tonight's keynote address
and senator bernie sanders is set for a
speech that aims to unify his
progressive base with joe biden's
campaign
president trump already turning in his
review
michelle obama whose speech is taped why
don't they tell me that i'll take my
speech next week on paper it's a lot
easier
i'll make sure it's perfect though every
word will be perfect
i don't do it i'll give it five or six
goes i'll say pick the best one what is
this they're taping their speeches i
just learned
that her speech is taped and that most
of them attack do you want to go to a
snooze
you know when you hear when you hear a
speech is taped
it's like there's nothing very exciting
about it right
and ahead of the convention a new poll
shows the race is tightening with
president trump
narrowing what once was a big gap with
biden
but a real clear politics polling
average shows biden holding steady and
his advantage over
president trump for now all right so
this is usually the beginning of the
official on switch for the campaigns
greg gutfeld um what do you expect as
you see president trump doing counter
programming right he's going to go out
go to the battleground states and figure
out a way to have a different storyline
than the democrats want
good it sounds like you're you're doing
the show from like
uh a water theme park i don't know if
you could hear it
oh you can hear it you
there is blue sky coming this way so i
think we're going to be
in better shape so i'll just turn it
over to you from to make whatever sort
of comment you'd like
well you know um in terms of it's a
weird kind of thing about the counter
programming
because trump counter programs even when
he's not
there like he puts the democrats in a
weird spot because if you're for law and
order or a common sense response to
to crime and violence which trump is and
pretty much everybody is then as a
democrat you can't voice that same
desire
because then if you say hey reform's
great but chaos is wrong
then you're evil by association right
you sound like you're for trump
if you just voice some kind of common
sense you agree with the evil orange
monster
so instead you decided to spend three
hours probably like on the on the
identity politic factions of the voters
and you have to strike a balance between
the scathing criticism
of american values because you know
we're racist we're sexist
imperialists bent on oppression but then
at the same time
asking for your vote so the a political
voter has to sit home and go wow they
really hate america but they want me to
vote for him
i don't know jesse i was thinking that
as president has done these two events
today
um that he has a different demeanor when
he's out and about right he's not at the
white house podium
at the in the briefing room um he it
feels a little bit more like in his
element he seems to love to campaign
what'd you take away from it well it
looks like they found out
what the magic touch is going to be you
throw him in there into a
hanger and you have people socially
distanced outside
and then he just riffs live and he does
it in a battleground and then he gets in
and gets out while joe's
asleep in the basement i think you're
going to see a lot more of this but
you know the democrats usually tell you
what their problem is dana
but you have to know where to look for
it luckily i know where to look for it
okay when the democrats say this week is
all about unity
that means they're not united they did
this in 2016.
now they're doing it again the
democratic party is basically
two factions the people who are crazy
and don't care
if you know they're crazy and the people
that are crazy
but try not to have everybody find out
they're crazy
so this week is going to be a
combination of these two people just
throwing a lot of taped
speeches at you i tried not to be
offended by that sometimes waters world
is on tape
i might have to start going live but it
does look like
biden has no base and even barack obama
is nervous about joe getting it across
the finish line and i think the cnn poll
which you touted sending shock waves
throughout the democratic party because
now the president's
cut 10 points into the biden lead and in
battlegrounds it's dead even
and that's still under sampling
republicans by six points
and not likely voters still only calling
registered voters so that skills against
the enthusiasm gap right there but
i did a deep dive into historical
polling
this weekend and this is what i found
out
guess how many times a republican
presidential nominee
has been leading in the race in the
third week of august
i think one time in 20 years
and it was 20 years ago it was george w
bush was ahead in the third week
of august against al gore but but these
things don't happen for republicans
it's always a big come-from-behind win
all right waters world we're going to
keep going
juan i wanted to ask you about this i
was actually surprised to hear oh can we
look at each other
they don't want me to look at you we're
together i don't know we're looking at
the boxes
okay so um it's the rain it's the rain
they fear that the rain would come back
time together or like screwing it up all
right so bernie sanders apparently
has been telling people that getting
along with the biden people has been
much better than in 2016 when the bernie
sanders people tried
to unify with the clinton people is that
something you have heard and do you
think that will maybe help them
as they try to kick things off tonight
there's no doubt about it what a
what what a distinct improvement it is
in terms of human
relationships between bernie sanders and
joe biden as opposed to
bernie sanders and hillary clinton joe
biden and bernie sanders actually get
along can have conversations and
the evidence is that they've been
working since
biden claimed the nomination to bring
both
factions of the party together but
tonight is not about
placating any split within the party and
crazy as i am because i'm a democrat uh
you know the fact that john kasich the
republican former governor of ohio
former gop nominee
is speaking as evidence that this is not
about placating the left
tonight is about michelle obama that's
what we're going to be talking about in
the morning
michelle obama with her 37 million
instagram followers with her 67 percent
approval rating obviously bipartisan you
don't get those numbers unless
women on both sides and that's the point
the target audience here
are people who listen to michelle obama
i just was informed we have a preview
sought from michelle obama so let's play
that and we'll get to katie
he is a profoundly decent man guided by
faith he was a terrific vice president
he knows what it takes to rescue an
economy
beat back a pandemic and lead our
country
one last word on that well i think that
again when she talks about
the virus when she talks about race
relations
when she talks about the fact that she
said recently that
you know the whole atmosphere these days
with the quarantine and the politics
is just depressing she's speaking
on a level that resonates it penetrates
with a lot of americans when
the most memorable line from the 2016
convention
was michelle obama's when they go low we
go high
all right so katie one of the things he
mentions uh former ohio governor
john kasich he's a republican he has
some speaking time tonight i don't think
that packs as big a punch
as the democrats apparently do because
they are giving him
more speaking time than alexandria
ocasio-cortez
yeah i think juan is right in the sense
that they're trying to
move the party into a more moderate
direction while also
placating the bernie sanders portion of
the party because in the swing states
that joe biden really needs voters to
come out and support him like michigan
and wisconsin bernie sanders locked down
a significant
percentage of the vote in the primary
and last time around they saw what it's
like to lose if they don't go out and
support the democratic nominee but in
terms of the theme tonight
for the democrats you know it's all
about unity tonight will be a lot about
race
but democrats have to be very careful
about pushing too far
on the identity politics and and this
idea that they are
telling americans that they are a racist
country that all you know their
they have this inherent racism that they
need to address
um i think that's something that they
did after eight years of obama people
got really tired of it they elected
president trump
um you can want racial reform without
demagoguing about it and insulting the
very people who you're trying to get to
vote for you
so they should be cautious on on that
note